et chaibi merci d'être en direct avec
nous sur rt france bonsoir alors on le
disait après le maroc tunis puis alger
attentes gérald darmanin pour négocier
l'expulsion d'étrangers fichiers hors
radicalisation à caractère terroriste
c'est une mission délicate et complexe
qui attend le ministre de l'intérieur
n'est ce pas oui c'est une mission
délicate et complexe mais je ne doute
pas un seul instant que gérald darmanin
trouvera auprès de son homologue
d'afrique charfeddine un ministre de
l'intérieur tunisien tout à fait j'ai
envie de dire ouverts au dialogue est
ouvert à la coopération entre la entre
la france et la tunisie sur ce sujet là
en particulier
donc oui c'est un sujet sensible du des
deux côtés de toute manière que ce soit
du côté français ou du côté tunisien
le sujet est sensible pour les deux pays
parce que le terrorisme
bien sûr il a frappé la france de
manière absolument terrible mais il a
aussi frappé la tunisie la tunisie
j'ai envie de dire à la paye également
un lourd tribut donc c'est un sujet sur
lequel je ne doute pas un seul instant
que gérald darmanin est un fixeur fait
ils trouveront des points de convergence
la tunisie accepterait de récupérer ces
terroristes qui sont aujourd'hui sur le
sol français de les accueillir sur le
sol tunisien
je ne peux pas parler à la place du
ministre tunisien de l'intérieur on
verra les rencontres que va avoir le
ministre de l'intérieur demain avec son
homologue tunisien
je peux comprendre également qui aurait
eu une série de consultations j'ai avec
excusez moi j'ai perdu de la connexion
je vous disais qu'il va avoir toute une
série de d'entretiens avec les autorités
tunisiennes donc à ce stade je suis dans
l'incapacité de vous dire si la tunisie
va accepter la demande française
mais je ne doute pas un seul instant
qu'il va y avoir encore une fois comme
je viens de vous le dire des points de
convergence du côté des tunisiens
quelles sont les réactions notamment
dans les médias avant cette rencontre
en bas la réaction elle et elle est tout
à fait comme celle qu'on pouvait
attendre à savoir qu' il ya une
nécessité de renforcer cette coopération
entre la france et la tunisie
mais j'ai même envie de dire que au delà
de la coopération franco tunisienne d'un
point de vue sécuritaire je pense que la
coopération elle doit être euro
méditerranéenne cette coopération
euro-méditerranéenne elle doit vraiment
comment dirais-je prendre ce point
d'équilibré à tunis mais il faut qu'il y
ait vraiment combattre sont fortes et de
la méditerranée en passant par une
coopération des services de
renseignement par exemple aujourd'hui
est ce qu'elle est suffisamment fort
cette coopération selon lou excusez moi
parce que j'étais vraiment un problème
de connexion dont du coup alors que sa
coupe et peut-être cette dernière
question ça pourrait effectivement
passer par un à renfort des services de
renseignement par exemple entre la
tunisie et la france
écoutez pour moi il ya deux choses
essentielles premièrement renforcer la
coopération franco-tunisienne ce sera
fait à n'en pas douter
je pense surtout qu'il faut renforcer la
coopération euro-méditerranéenne parce
que je prends exemple sur le dialogue
qu'on appelle le dialogue 5 + 5 c'est à
dire le dialogue entre les cinq pays de
la rive nord et les cinq pays la rive
sud de la méditerranée
le dernier dialogue qui a eu entre les
cinq ministres de l'intérieur de la rive
nord et de la rive sud date de 2015
le dernier comment dirais-je
regroupement des mises l'intérieur du
nord et du sud de la méditerranée date
de 2015 c'était à lisbonne bon je ne
doute pas que les mises l'intérieur
doivent s'appelait et doivent entre tat
entretenir pardon un dialogue entre eux
mais je pense qu'il faut déjà relancer
le dialogue c'est un peu ça le bénisse
mon intérieur et la deuxième chose
essentielle c'est une véritable
politique de développement pour la
tunisie
et j'ajoute d'ailleurs je voudrais
vraiment mettre l'accent sur le discours
qu'avait fait le président sayed le 2
août dernier à sfax
oui parlais je cite des embarcations de
la mort il avait vu juste ce sont des
embarcations de la mort est la réponse à
apporter
il ya bien sûr
sécuritaire la solution sécuritaire à
apporter mais il ya aussi une solution
de développement développement
économique développement social et là
j'ai envie de dire que nos deux rives
doivent jouer un rôle en ce sens et doit
vous même joué un grand rôle pour que
nous puissions développer cette
coopération gagnant gagnant entre le
nord et le sud c'est le travail de karim
amellal pour le compte de la france
puisqu'il est ambassadeur et délégué
interministériel aux grands pour la
méditerranée mais j'appelle également le
président sayyed a nommé un haut
représentant la méditerranée pour
travailler sur ces questions là en lien
avec les autres pays de la rive sud la
tunisie est un leader de la rive sud
elle est un leader diplomatique allen
voix qui compte et elle doit justement
s'affirmer notamment sur ces questions
merci beaucoup
khaled salhi d'avoir répondu à une
question je rappelle que vous êtes
président de l'association pour la
promotion de la coopération et de
l'amitié entre la france et la tunisie
niche à merci